la forma en que pensaba era que
podías cuidar tu salud
o cumplir con tus obligaciones,
y siempre era uno a costa del otro.
Ahora, luego de cientos de estas reuniones a pie,
he aprendido algunas cosas.
Primero, hay algo increíble
al salir realmente de la caja
que te lleva a pensar fuera de la caja.
Bien sea la naturaleza o el ejercicio mismo, de verdad funciona.
Y segundo, probablemente la más reflexiva,
es lo mucho que podemos
mantener los problemas en oposición
cuando en realidad no es así.
Y si vamos a resolver problemas
y mirar el mundo desde una perspectiva realmente distinta,
ya sea en el gobierno o en los negocios,
cuestiones ambientales o creación de empleos,
quizá podemos pensar cómo replantear esos problemas
considerando que ambas partes son posibles.
Porque fue cuando eso ocurrió
con esta idea de caminar y platicar
que las cosas se volvieron realizables, sostenibles y viables.
Comencé esta charla hablando acerca del trasero,
así que terminaré con la línea final, que es,
caminen y platiquen.
Pongan el ejemplo.
Les sorprenderá ver cómo el aire fresco impulsa el pensamiento innovador,
y de esa forma,
incorporarán a su vida un conjunto de ideas completamente nuevo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)